a bartender robbed at gunpoint is forced
to pay back the thousands of dollars
that was stolen now the video obtained
by the eight news now i-team showing the
moment his life changed forever and now
he's talking exclusively to our i-team
as he plans to sue his former employer
our own david charns here now with the
interview you will only see on 8 news
now david brian denise you may have
heard about this story on social media
when edward parker first talked about
this robbery and his repayment to the
bar where he worked tonight he and his
attorneys have filed a lawsuit asking a
judge to decide if this bar should be
punished
a quiet friday morning inside the law
dualapai quickly turning violent when an
armed gunman storms in demanding cash
the bartender with his hands up is 42
year old edward parker it's december
2020 we're in the middle of covid
people are fighting for jobs left and
right
i suppose i let the idea of having a
steady job with steady income cloud my
judgment cloud is judgment he says
because hours after handing over 3 900
dollars parker says his employer told
him he had to pay the money back i
wasn't thinking right i just had a gun
shoved in my face and i signed the
document this document a signed contract
saying 300 dollars would come out of his
paycheck until the full amount
dollars and 3937.00
cents was all paid off what was the time
between when you were robbed and when
you signed that document
three to four hours tops parker now
lives out of state his attorneys say the
lodge coerced him to sign that contract
it's a demand for repayment for money
that was taken from him it's the most
outrageous thing i've ever seen it's not
right he allowed this armed assailant to
come in do what he was threatening to do
and leave without without getting
himself hurt without getting any of the
patrons who actually were there hurt so
he did everything right his employer did
everything wrong after paying back the
money in those installments parker says
he was fired after taking an approved
vacation i was devastated i loved that
company i'd worked very hard for them i
couldn't believe they had done this to
me
devastated he says he hopes the lawsuit
proves no employee is too small in that
business owners particularly in the
restaurant industry will be held
accountable i'm hoping
to show them that i can lead by example
and if you guys have problems with
employers don't be afraid to speak up
you're not alone out there
now the good news is police did find the
robber charging him for a string of
incidents across the valley the state
labor commission facilitated a
settlement with parker and the lodge for
55-hundred dollars which his lawyers say
he did not accept we did reach out to
the lodge and did not hear back i'm
david charns live local now